when do you think we might know
what worlds we're living in whether
that's a biden landslide a trump win
or a contested election we'll know
pretty soon
on election night i think by midnight we
should have a good sense
as to as you said which world we live in
a lot of this depends on
results from florida and north carolina
which we should know by the end of the
night
but even in the states that are not
competitive places like texas
and ohio we'll have some nuggets of
information as to whether this
is a sort of wave the election for one
or the other candidate or whether it's
going to go
into overtime in places like
pennsylvania wisconsin and michigan
to take it back a step let's establish
why 2020 is different from past
elections where we normally do see a
result on the night even if it's
very late i suppose the question this
time is all these different types of
votes that people have to
count mail-in ballots early ballots as
well as votes on the day
is it which part of that chain do you
think is going to cause the most
friction
the mail-in ballots are really the
distinctive feature of this election so
over 82 million americans have
requested or will receive mail-in
ballots
and that's double what we've had in the
past and
it's not just the number of mail-in
ballots but it's the states that are
increasing their mail ballot usage so
places like pennsylvania
wisconsin and north carolina don't have
an extensive experience with mail-in
balloting
so it's going to take them some time to
finish the count we know that other
states in america have had a long
history
of you know adequately conducting
the whole process through maryland
ballots
but as you say there's newcomers
particularly pennsylvania that
politically is really important how
confident
are you given what you've seen over the
years that this system
can cope well there are new challenges
that's for sure
uh but in some ways we don't have a lot
of choice here i mean we need
to move to voting with social distance
and the most
distant way for people to vote is to
vote from home
but they will have ample polling places
as well i think pennsylvania in
particular
is going to have some challenges uh
michigan also has said that they won't
release the results until about friday
of next week um and wisconsin wisconsin
suggests that they will they'll actually
have results within 48 hours or so
um but i'm confident that the election
officials
uh are prepared for this uh they've been
preparing all summer
to some extent the best thing that
happened was that the pandemic happened
during the primary elections so you
could have a dry run
through and have all the mistakes made
then as opposed to on election day but
there's no question that there's some
significant stress being put on election
officials in this election
so let's paint a picture of um election
night itself
and we might actually have a sort of
false dawn with a result might we
because
we might see all of the on the day votes
going to one candidate and then the
trickle in of the mail-in ballots over
several days
which changes the outcome so how on
earth do tv networks or anybody
call the election yeah most of what
we've been talking about
these days is the so-called red mirage
followed by a blue wave or a blue
shift where the election day vote would
heavily favor
favor president trump and then the
absentee ballots would later favor uh
joe biden
that's actually not exactly what i think
is going to happen because there are
some places like
arizona and florida where they will
count and release
the earliest vote totals including the
absentee ballots before they do the
election day
returns and so we may have a blue mirage
followed by a red mirage followed by a
blue shift
but the general the general point is
right which is that
um the absentee ballots are going to be
heavily favoring the democrats here
in some states it's twice you know two
to one advantage on the absentee ballots
and so the networks have to
contextualize these results
and to be clear that the early results
are not predictive of the final outcome
how likely do you think we'll have a
bush
gore-like scenario that we saw in 2000
in florida because both teams are
legallying up aren't they there's
already
more than a hundred cases going through
the courts
yes well there's well over 300 cases
that have gone through the courts at
this point um
if you include everything from the
primaries to today
because there are new legal issues that
the pandemic is posing
uh the question as to whether we will
have another bush versus gore really
just depends on the margin
right so in a close election where one
state is going to be outcome
determinative then yes we have a bush
versus gore situation
the polls right now don't suggest that
but you know we've known that the polls
have been wrong before and most notably
four years ago
and so no one is uh taking anything for
granted right now
um so so in order to have a bush versus
gore scenario it has to be
a close election coming down to one
state with sort of clear legal issues
that will
decide the outcome so the nightmare
scenario that a lot of people think
about
is a close election that comes down to
pennsylvania where the absentee ballots
are determinative
now again that that is a low probability
event but
it's not outside the realm of
possibility and i think that
uh you know we should be prepared for
that possibility that there will be
legal wrangling after election day
let's talk about that crisis scenario
president trump has talked extensively
about mail-in ballots and being you know
voter fraud
illegitimacy of ballots counted after
election day we know that pennsylvania
has through the week to count
some of these uh ballots that aren't
cast on the day so is there a world in
which
legal challenges are successful in
actually stopping any counting beyond
election night and kind of throws the
whole result into
into the air well it depends what the
objections are
so it's it's too difficult right now to
figure out what the
uh legal vehicle would be to try to stop
uh the uh counting of absentee ballots
uh presumably there would be allegations
of fraud as you said which
and they've been seeding that argument
already in the pre-election period
and the argument would be there's
something inherently tainted about the
absentee ballots but it's not as if
this is the first election that might be
decided by absentee ballots we have
experience we have precedent and how to
deal with this there are state laws
that provide for recounts and so there
will be a legal process in pennsylvania
or elsewhere
to determine the legality of voters and
ballots each
state has its own quirks when it comes
to the way that they're both processing
and delivering of course the different
pieces of paper for people to vote on so
with
the 2000 election it was a hanging chads
we're looking at naked ballots this time
in pennsylvania what have you seen
that you're either heartened or
concerned by because anecdotally
i've got neighbors for instance in dc
who say they've received ballots for
four
previous uh residents in the property
which is a worry right well receiving
more ballots is not necessarily a
problem
if um those voters are ineligible and
they're not going to have their vote
counted
i mean there is a process for verifying
the identity of voters when they return
their mail ballots
we have if you go to
healthyelections.org we have an entire
signature matching memo there so you can
see how different jurisdictions match
signatures in order to prevent
fraud but there are it's not just the
issue of signature matching that's just
top of mind right one of the things that
i think we should be concerned about
is the number of ballots that will be
received too late to be counted it's
going to be in the hundreds of thousands
that's one of the reasons you've seen
all this action at the u.s supreme court
in these final in this final week
over the deadlines is because we know
that because of postal delays and other
things that they're going to be hundreds
of thousands of ballots that will not be
arriving but related to that and just
the general sort of
challenge with this election is you have
millions of voters who have never voted
a mail ballot before
who are for the first time having to
navigate that process
and while over a series of elections you
can figure it out for a lot of people
they might find it
surprising that you have to sign the
outside of a ballot because they thought
it was anonymous or
they might not know what the deadlines
are or some of the other technicalities
like you mentioned
naked ballots the idea that you have to
have a secrecy sleeve
inside an envelope in order for a ballot
to count in pennsylvania those are all
new processes for people to work through
what does it take if this all kind of
falls apart through wednesday thursday
next week what does it take for the
supreme court to get involved as they
did famously in 2000
is that kind of weeks of wrangling away
before it gets to that stage
well it probably will be uh at least a
week or two it depends on what the
nature of the controversy is right
because right now
we're sort of speculating that it would
follow the same path or playbook as bush
versus gore
but there are a lot of other things that
could happen we could have issues with
violence in polling places we could have
issues with destruction and balance i
mean there's all
kinds of pathologies that we as election
law experts look at
um if it comes to absentee ballots then
there will be a week or two
of the counting and processing and
verification of the absentee ballots
and then if it's still close then
there'll be challenges to those absentee
ballots and then a recount
following along the lines of bush versus
gore it would go through the state
system
and then end up at the supreme court we
know back in 2000
uh that the state attorney general there
a republican
played a role we know that the
republicans were very
quick to try and steer the narrative and
there was a concern that al gore had
sort of
lost the political winds because of that
early concession and he never really
made it
back so in the eyes of many in the
public
he was a sore loser if you like do you
think that's what we'll see if it's
contested this
time is both teams really trying to very
quickly leap
on the story so that neither can be
suggested as a
loser in this scenario i think the most
important factor is who is perceived as
being ahead
as we approach the legal wrangling right
i mean if you talk to the lawyers for
for the bush administration or the bush
campaign at the time
they'll say that they were constantly
looking at the bottom of the tv
which would always say 500 votes ahead
or
2 000 votes ahead and so long as you
maintain that advantage
in public perception it's seen as you
are ahead and the other
candidate is trying to take that away
from you so i think that is quite
important so it is possible that we will
see false claims of victory
uh with partial results on election
night or shortly thereafter
what's the impact do you think
potentially of the supreme court
shift recently obviously with amy county
barrett appointed to the supreme court
she actually recused herself
this week from two cases that were going
through the courts but
conservatives have a six three majority
now
what might that mean for team trump
when they're looking at this well the uh
what we've seen in these early cases is
that there have been situations in which
the court has been divided four to four
uh with chief justice roberts joining
the three more liberal justices in order
to
keep in place state court decisions that
were sort of pro-voting rights
relaxing the deadlines in the light and
so she could be a critical tie-breaking
vote
in these cases and the question is going
to be how strictly
uh to interpret state laws to what
extent will you give deference to state
courts as opposed to state legislatures
and so i think this appointment at this
time if she participates in these cases
could be quite significant
i'm going to ask you to look into your
crystal ball here the question which
lots of listeners ask us is
what happens if trump refuses to leave
the white house
he is you know if this if the blue shift
through next week changes the outcome
and we
and we feel that we have a president
biden by the end of next week
what does trump do well we don't really
know uh the constitution
assumes a peaceful transfer of power it
doesn't provide for it
and so ever since george washington
we've had peaceful uh transfers of power
now you know on january 20th if
president trump has lost the election he
loses authority as president he can
still
even if he's in the lincoln uh bedroom
in the white house it doesn't mean he's
still president
the authority then goes to uh uh vice
president biden but at that point
you know we would be in new
constitutional territory here
uh how that would be navigated what role
the courts would play how the military
would
uh pay attention to conflicting orders
right that that's something that
really is for uh you know for another
day for us to figure out let's hope that
we're not there
december the 8th though is a key date
isn't it and all of this tell us a
little bit about that
so there are a few key dates in thinking
about this election
obviously november 3rd when we finish
casting ballots
december 8th is what's known as the safe
harbor deadline of the electoral count
act which basically says that if a state
has gotten all of its
um ballots counted or finished its
election made its choice by that date
that the candidate who won by that date
will be the presumptive
victor of the electoral college votes
from that state
and then the electoral college meets a
week later on december 14th
where they will in each of the states
sort of declare who they have voted for
if there is still a controversy for
example if in
in a state you have different bodies
that send different slates of electors
that gets resolved at the u.s house of
representatives in the senate
on january 6th with the newly elected
house
and senate and there constitutionally
vested with the power to determine
between conflicting slates of electors
there's something that's called the
election administrators prayer
and that is oh god whatever happens
please don't let it be close
and and that that because once it's if
it's a close election then all the
frailties of the electoral system then
come into full bloom and are seen as
outcome determinative
and so hopefully we'll have a clear
outcome where we'll we'll know who won
on election day
and it is worth saying i think that
there are states which are good at
counting their absentee
ballots and their early votes and might
bring out you know their
crucial decisive states that might bring
us a result so if for example
joe biden is doing really well in
florida arizona and north carolina
all of which are good at doing this
stuff quickly we might actually know on
the night it's not it's not
kind of uh guaranteed disaster is it
that's right and well that we might not
know who actually
won those states at at that point we
might know who is ahead
and based on the data that we have early
on
uh november 3rd we might be able to make
inferences about the likelihood as to
whether it's a blowout or whether it's
going to be a close outcome
nate personally thank you so much for
talking us through quite a complicated
tapestry of stuff
and enjoy election night thank you